Star Wars Celebration is beginning with
this presentation of Star Wars The Force
awakens which I know you guys have been
waiting to hear about for a long long
time but it's not just this room it's
not just the folks who are waiting all
night to get in here this is being a
live stream let's hear it for those
people the diehards but it's not just
here in Anaheim it is around the world
this is an unprecedented live streaming
event it is in 23 countries we have
people in theaters around the world it's
it's live streaming in China which is
also extremely rare and this is the 10th
the 10th celebration but let's bring out
to people who are opening that window
again for us please welcome the director
of the force awakens' also the co-writer
and the producer JJ Abrams
as well as the producer of the force
awakens and the president of Lucasfilm
the person who's creating a whole new
series of films to advocate a
how many out there waited all night long
those words hit the screen with that
incredible music and it was that moment
on that just transported me it was the
first time a movie made me laugh that
way and made me believe in another world
that way and it was really George
Lucas's brilliance not only creating
these incredible characters and this
amazing universe but also that it it it
had such heart and the biggest thing for
me is it had such hope and that to me
was incredibly powerful even eleven
years old to say that when George asked
me to have lunch with him and it was
almost three years to the day that I sat
down with George in a small little
restaurant in New York and he said I'm
retiring and I'm thinking about moving
on and I'd like somebody to come in and
carry on this legacy and I thought he
was going to ask me recommendations on
who might do that and I said who are you
thinking about and he said well I was
thinking about you and needless to say
and to indulge me a minute for the for
the folks in the Creature Shop not just
applause and cheering could we could
everybody make their best wookie roar
for those guys right now I want to hear
thousand
that's cool thank you close to a Bruce
Springsteen concert the incredible thing
was when I was literally leaving Essen
and going back to London where we were
prepping the movie and I turned to our
creature shop and I said you know I
think we've got to hire those guys at a
celebration let's track down who they
were and we hired Oliver and Lee would
you like to meet the droid mechanics
let's bring out Lee Towers II and Oliver
steeples and friend
so lien Oliver you were you were once
guys out there in the audience now
you're up here on the stage you are fans
who have now contributed to the Star
Wars universe yeah give people a little
sense of what that feels like
there's absolutely nothing that prepares
it like just sit here several years ago
I was out there sort of watching the
stage and Here I am it's like how to put
into words and you're please walk on
bb-8
I will tell you that we could not have
ended up with three more talented and
wonderful actors and people we have
Oscar Isaac
we have Daisy Ridley and John boyega
what can you tell us about the
characters they play rape in I I think
rather than me tell anything about them
I think they should know it's pretty
much please welcome Daisy Ridley John
boyega and Oscar Isaac
where do we discover ray in this movie
Daisy hey y'all again um we discover ray
on the desert planet
gee aku she is a scavenger in like a
ship graveyard and she is like
completely self-sufficient she does
everything for herself and very solitary
until she meets another character and an
adventure begins
Finn is the first character we see in
this in the force awakens he was the
first face that appeared in that teaser
trailer last November you're John he's
in a he's in a stormtrooper uniform but
people are wondering is he in disguise
is he an actual stormtrooper so tell us
how do we meet Finn in this movie well
first of all Star Wars Celebration
what's up
to do that so we find Finn he's in
incredible danger and the way in which
he decides to react to this danger
changes his life number one and launches
him into the Star Wars universe in a
very unique way so I can't wait for you
guys to see it Oscar Isaac the only
character on stage who has two names Poe
Dameron we see him piloting an x-wing
fighter we saw you in the uniform there
so tell us about tell us about playing
this guy who is he he's the best
freaking pilot in the galaxy
he's been sent on a mission by a certain
princess and he ends up coming across
mr. john boyega's character and their
fates are forever intertwined there are
moments where the pressure of what we're
doing the responsibilities of what we're
doing honoring the legacy but using the
legacy to tell a brand-new story that
moves forward it makes the fans proud
it's it's the most important thing that
we're all working on and I will say that
though there are moments of I don't know
I'd say sheer horror at what that is the
reality is I've never had more fun in my
life working on anything and the the
opportunity far outweighs the risk of
this and I can't wait for you sooner I
don't think there's anything more
important in the Star Wars universe than
the fans you guys talk to us all the
time about everything and we take that
really seriously so one of the things
that's been noted about this film is
Star Wars has always pushed the
boundaries of visual effects but you are
kind of taking a retro approach this
time around you build a lot of practical
sets
Wow
I hear people like that we needed a
standard time we needed to set a
standard that was real that felt like
you know you knew the people were in
those places the way the light interacts
with the set you wanna you want it to be
legitimate you want it to be authentic
and so building as much as we possibly
could was really the mandate who is more
excited the newcomers like yourselves or
the veteran actors from the original
trilogy and the original actors were
coming back to a universe they
absolutely loved and we were joining a
universe we were yet to love as much as
we do now so we were all excited and
then coming here today has made it so
much more exciting like all of us are so
cannot wait to show you guys what we've
done but there are some other folks who
are here people you know people you love
we're gonna bring them out too so please
welcome you know him as c-3po Anthony
Daniels
princess diplomat freedom fighter
Princess Leia
Barry Fisher
Chewbacca himself here may you
and Luke Skywalker Mark Hamill
I've got to say thank you for your your
kindness your support your affection for
the whole project and especially in my
case for a character that I am very very
fond of it's kinda nice to get back into
first suit because I can go anywhere in
the world and so be comfortable and also
the mere fact that I wouldn't have been
associated with these guys if I didn't
have the walking carpet as a certain
young lady could be so it'd be great you
guys are what Wiz is all about and we
are there we get to enjoy it and I hope
everybody else does
it should be great to enjoy it
sis Leia was always very fashion-forward
are we gonna see any return to those
classic hair buns from the original
movie this time around the buns are you
know they're tired now so we're probably
not going to have the futuristic buns
but I think we have an alternate thing
that you'll be varying into which is not
the metal bikini just have a simple
message not just to all of you in this
room but to people watching us around
the globe and that's a simple thank you
because if it weren't for the UPF s
ultra passionate fans we wouldn't be
here and it never ceases to amaze me and
I'm so grateful for your support your
enthusiasm and yes your passion because
over the years my entire adult life I
felt such love from you and you're more
than just fans you're family
it's it's surprisingly quiet because
everybody's holding their phones
so these guys have to say goodbye now
thank you guys everyone so much for
coming out thank you for for joining us
at celebration for kicking it off right
so honestly and I know that we've said
thank you a lot to you guys but I just
need to say it one more time on behalf
of Cathy and myself and to everyone
who's watching who's not here we cannot
thank you enough the the energy that you
guys are throwing our way is evidence of
the force and we couldn't be more
grateful
you